(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] And you got like a little-
- God, look at all of ya.
- A little cowboy boot
kind of thing going.
I'm into what you wearing.
- I did this for you.
- I feel like I will wear that tomorrow.
- And remembered to throw in a boot.
I know, I would wear that.
- I'm like, that's, I know I was-
- We'll switch.
- I literally, Candace,
my stylist looked at me
when I walked in and she was like,
"so you wanna go like comfortable?"
And I was like, please.
(all laugh)
You know like days you're just tired
and you're like, I don't
feel like sucking in.
So it's nice to see y'all.
It's so funny-
- You too.
- 'Cause we're neighbors.
I never see you.
My daughter did.
And you mentioned
something about a play date
and she will not stop talking about it.
I was like, she was being nice.
- Oh, my God, no, no.
- I was like, I know, but she was-
- I opened all of your coffees.
- Oh my God-
- I opened everything and I was like, Ben,
you ordered all this stuff, but-
- All of my stuff.
- It's nothing that we drink.
And then I saw it said, Kelly.
I was like, oh God.
- I know and I usually order
it for people that come
in the morning to be nice,
to help out with the kids, everything.
And literally any Target
orders, Amazon coffee orders,
they all go to your house.
- I've opened your sinks.
- I don't know why
people have a hard time with my address.
- I've opened your sinks
and then the saddest part-
- 'Cause I'm renovating.
- You're renovating.
- Yes.
- So there were, I opened four big boxes.
So four sinks and I was like,
did I order sinks?
Like these aren't mine.
I had to be like,
was this one o'clock on a Unisom
and did I order a bunch of sinks?
And then it was like, Kelly.
I was like, oh, for God's sake.
- I don't know why people have
a hard time with my address,
but whatever.
But how are your kids doing?
- They're good.
- [Kelly] They're good.
- They're great, yeah.
- Yeah, they're giants.
I don't understand what's happening.
- I hear them playing in the backyard.
- It's pickleball.
It's pretty serious pickleball.
- Yeah, we're big into pickleball now.
- So I just got that
'cause somebody told me here
on set, I think it Wiess,
told me about pickleball
and I'd never heard of it.
- [Melissa] Well it's-
- Do you play?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Yes, intensely.
- There's a stupid Sunday thing.
We wear all whites just to be extra stupid
and to look like ghosts.
(Kelly laughs)
I like it 'cause I grew up
playing tennis and I love it.
But now I'm like-
- [Kelly] Oh.
- I'm gonna shatter all of it.
- [Ben] Yeah.
- Which I can't play tennis anymore.
- When we first played,
Melissa got really competitive
and was just rifling balls at our kids.
And I was like, "Mooch let's go easy."
She's like "No."
(Melissa laughs)
- Teach them, teach them.
They're gonna have to win for real.
- [Melissa] There's something
about a paddle, but then also,
if I see a ball, literally
in my head I'm like,
be nice, be nice, be
nice, be nice, be nice,
be nice you son of a (beep).
And something takes over
from years of playing tennis.
- Yeah.
- And like I have hit
my kids and I'm like,
I'm a monster and I'm fine
until right when I'm about to swing,
then it's like, I'm gonna murder it.
And I can't control myself.
- [Kelly] I didn't know
that you played tennis.
So I did not.
And I got this house just
because of the location, really?
And there happens to be a tennis court
in my backyard-
- [Melissa] Have you played at all?
- That we skate on.
- Yeah, yeah
- And we do a lot of other
things on it and ride bikes.
But we don't play tennis, yeah.
But now I wanna play tennis with you
'cause I want you to
get really competitive.
(Melissa and Kelly laugh)
- It's not pretty.
It's really not pretty.
- And then I want you to watch
just two crazy women.
- [Ben] I'll be like, no, no, no, no, no,
okay, fine.
- You're like ow, ow, ow.
- So wait, so Ben posted this photo
and said circumstances
shall remain mysterious.
(audience laughs)
I mean, I live next door to you,
like, what's going on in your house?
- [Melissa] This is Friday night, truly.
- Yep, truly.
- This is Friday night.
I'm not kidding.
We've done it for over a year.
We have a group.
We started as movie, a
movie Zoom, oh my God.
It's a lot to look at.
- Yep.
- This is from, what is it, Emile Zola?
- [Ben] "The Life of Emile Zola."
- [Melissa] "The Life of Emile Zola."
- [Kelly] Amazing.
- We've watched every Best Picture winner
and we started over a year ago.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And by the time we got
to "Lawrence of Arabia,"
we had one of our friends, Steve Mallory,
who's in "God's Favorite Idiot,"
he showed up, he joined
the group on that one
'cause it's his favorite movie
and he showed up in full costume.
- Love.
- And it's a bunch of actors,
and directors and producers.
And literally people were
like, oh we're doing that?
Okay, and so one by one every-
- [Kelly] It got competitive.
- And now we show up every Friday on Zoom,
- [Kelly] I love that.
- In full costume, there's some drinks.
And then we do a Q&A.
We watch the movie during
the week, we do a Q&A,
and then there's dumb
prizes for whoever wins it.
- [Kelly] I love this.
So did this all start in,
like in Zoom, in quarantine?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's so cool.
- 'Cause we were like-
- What do we do?
- We hadn't seen anyone and
we're like, we're going crazy.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh my god, I love that.
- Yeah, so it becomes a
thing where now on Friday
we're like, I need to be
a bagel for the movie.
(Melissa and Kelly laugh)
And everybody's like, how
do we make a bagel suit?
- Some have been so elaborate.
Some week, I went through
a period where I was making
really huge things and Ben's like,
"We need to be able to sit down."
- For "Forrest Gump," we
were the box of chocolates.
It was pretty amazing.
(audience laugh)
- Oh, my gosh.
- [Melissa] It was like,
I made a box of chocolates
that's the size of that rug.
- [Kelly] Y'all are so fun.
- And then two of our heads came through,
and then I decorated it all.
But then it was like, oh God,
three hours is a long
time to stand like this.
(audience laughs)
Like I didn't think it through.
- [Kelly] All I'm feeling
is like your lazy apathetic neighbor.
(all laughs)
Like I'm like, by the way,
while you're doing that,
I'm just laying on my
couch going so tired.
So wait, you are about to be,
this is literally my kids,
like one of their favorite
characters all time is Ursula.
And you're about to do
this in the live action
"The Little Mermaid."
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Are you so, I
mean you have the best song.
"Poor Unfortunate Souls", yeah.
- It's so weird because
when I was a nanny,
I worked for this lovely,
the Ross family, hi Rosses,
and we watched "The Little
Mermaid" almost every night.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So I truly was like, for
three years I watched it
almost every night.
- Yeah.
- And to get to play it and
to work with Rob Marshall
and just the whole,
'cause I don't get to be
in your world of singing and
sliding down a clam shell.
- [Kelly] I know
- Truly, the clam shell was the
size of a house, I was like.
- [Kelly] I know, but
you have the best song.
Did you feel so powerful
singing that song?
- I was scared to death, and
then I worked with somebody
and then I was like, okay,
it's just a character,
I don't have to be a singer,
I can just be this character.
But I love that song.
And when it-
- Me too.
- When we finally recorded
it and they're like
that's it, you've got your song.
I literally burst out
crying cause I was like,
I don't get to go to
singing class anymore.
Like that's it?
- You don't get to go to
singing class, I love you.
- It'd weird if you kept
going, it would be odd.
- That would be weird?
Not your Friday night dress
up in a box of chocolates.
(audience laughs)
I was like, that's your line?
- That's mine.
- [Kelly] We found it,
yeah, I was like, okay.